the girag an experience I do bad shows
if I'm hungover I don't like my shows
they don't feel good they don't have the
flow to them
you know and I just I hate that feeling
I hate the feeling of being on stage and
it's it wouldn't be my fault if I was
hungover if I was hungover on stage like
it's my fault that I'm working it like
3/4 speed right now or it's not clicking
right now like that so well I wish I
could just have one but it's not
satisfying because you have one and then
you want a hundred and then and then you
drink a hundred and then you feel like
shit and like if I just drink one like
I've have one at lunch then it's like I
I want to go take a nap it really
you know a good hardcore four or a
gentleman six and then I'm done but like
I yeah you I feel pulled to it no is it
like Gollum in the ring no I just I
don't know what that means I just - yes
I just don't fish no no no no like why
it's us today it's precious
yes I don't you know what that is I
don't want you didn't would see the Lord
of the Rings you didn't see that the
Lord the ring I went to one of those and
it was so fucking long and every time
they would they would fade to black I'd
be like just roll the credits roll the
credits and then they would open up on
some big field and it's just like Jesus
get the fucking thing back to the guy so
we can get out of here
I hate I you know what I fucking hate
all of those movies and I fucking pay
people don't have a sense of humor about
the bullshit that they watched when they
were kids like adults who talk about
star wars like it isn't a fucking rule
with the movie now when you watch it I
mean like how bizarre about it so I was
making for the other night the other
night I came home I guess I got free
free cinemax which is the greatest
fucking channel ever they either would
24 hours a day they're either showing
the greatest movie ever or the worst
fucking movie ever and it's all
compelling as I watch like nine movies
in heroics fucking channels unbelievable
so I ended up flipping up uh because
later night they just had some sort of
you know soft
for porn which is ridiculous now when
you have the Internet so just was redone
sorry I got off of that so I went on to
vh1 uh and and they were playing this to
show metal mania and I was watching all
these bands in these videos that I just
thought was fuckin sick and they're into
the devil dude I was just by the end of
it I was like how was this better than
disco like why did disco get so much
shit like I'm not talking about like the
Iron Maiden's the Metallica's but you
know what I'm talking about that middle
of the fucking ground those people with
the spiked fucking gloves and all this
stupid shit Romney knew just it was
horseshit
it was fucking I watched it it was the
dumbest shit of it was embarrassing that
I I mean I moved granted I had all of
that music still on my ipod I'm not I'm
not above it but if someone were from
this generation were to come back and
tell me that music was awful and was
stupid I would laugh there's like
there's no way I could defend it isn't
it weird I mean you look at like if you
look at music or you look at movies
that's like one of the clearest examples
of like some sort of evolution or
progress is going on with humans because
like the the movies of the past like so
many of them are there so clunky and the
style of communicating is so artificial
it looks it's it's such a shit you know
representation of life and come on
here's six a real good move until the
sixty once they figured out you know
like just acting on film like those
people just learning how to do it so
everything was was gonna be not you know
let me tell you I'm very yeah that type
of acting had to go away with the
Brando's in the James Dean's and those
guys and then you had to have like the
there's a couple more like this movies
back there like Jack Lemmon the
apartment
well the Hustle is way ahead of his time
that the hustler is my name is Stanley
Kubrick yeah
that type of shit there was some deal
that we don't hold up though but though
the bad movies from the 60s in the 70s
you know watch like try to wash like
jaws 3d oh yeah no idea that that's a
bad one this is this a bit but they've
always had they still have movies on
shore I mean oh yeah I think a lot of
sure to this day that transformer shit
even though I didn't see it but if you
said I never I never vibe
with sci-fi people like sci-fi listeners
I always get trashed by them because I
just don't I just don't get unless you
don't get sci-fi at all know if it's
like aliens like it has to be
high-quality like aliens is like the
good fellows of that side like on like
top-shelf sci-fi I'm gonna be the Blade
Runner aliens and that type of shit but
if I'm just gonna go what you know oh
we're in Hoth I mean what the fuck
that's from what is Hoth is that that's
a Star Wars thing and I don't know what
yeah like one of those fucking things
look the action figures of shit it's
just did you like trains about it I
didn't like I didn't like Chewbacca you
know I didn't get Chewbacca it's like
dude you're a Pacific fucking awesome
gotta have around huge imagine you could
party with Bigfoot
I would totally party should be ripping
somebody's arms off he's shooting a gun
like he's a fucking psyches he's a
badass living is how to shoot guns too
he'll rip in fucking arms up but he can
also shoot you from a distance bitch
she's limited oh I liked you lot are
worthy I would totally hang out you know
what again no I didn't like about him he
was a follower well started he started
hanging out with all the humans next
thing he knows he's sitting upright in
chairs right right sipping little juicy
juices right yeah I wonder if he can
understand us could they understand him
they could speak that kadai so yeah I
think it was a language that we just
didn't understand it so that's a really
good thing every time not that many
wookies you know it's like Chewbacca and
like there's no other famous woman he
was like the dodo bird
that was no weird we're gonna be
destroyed on Twitter because we are Star
Wars knowledge sucks and never do
there's a fucking million wookies there
is a nation of wookies there is a
federation of wookies you know not what
you're talking about
there's nothing better than just just
having a gig fucking 10% knowledge of
this criticizing because it's just
driving some kid nuts
you